Okay. So we saw last time
that Louis wasn't so dumb.
He knew about her and Shaw's Theorem,
but he thought that so,
but he's still thought there was an
octet of electrons around the nucleus.
How could he think such a thing? Because
if you have inverse square force laws,
you can't have a static positions of
charge things unless they're right on top
of one another or blown apart.
So what did he think
that it's not an inverse square force law.
That cool ohms law breaks down when
you get to various small scale.
And Jj Thomson thought the same thing
and wrote here this two terms here.
The first one is that is cool ohms law
indeed, but there's this other thing,
c over r. So as long as our is
very big, you don't compare,
but you don't care about that term.
Right?
As long as it's very big compared to c
and c is a distance that something like
the size of atoms.
So once our,
once the distance of the things that
are interacting with one another,
the electron and the nucleus
say once they get near,
near the distance, see then this, this uh,
sorry,
got the back there,
then this c over r thing becomes
significant if our becomes very small,
right? And even changes the sign, right?
So what was attractive becomes repulsive.
So that would do okay then
for a structure, right?
That was in 1923 in 1926
just three years later,
quantum mechanics came along and showed
that cool ohms law was just fine.
Nothing wrong with cool ohms
law. It goes to much, much,
much tend to the 20th smaller distances
than the size of Adam's cool ohms.
Law Still Works,
right?
What was wrong was the way they treated
kinetic energy because kinetic energy,
quantum mechanics reformulates
so it gives you electron clouds.
And so what's a cloud is
not the positive charge.
Remember Jj Thomson had a positive sphere
of electricity in which he embedded
the electrons.
What's a cloud is the electrons
and nuclei are put in it to make,
to make molecules. Right?
So it's, it really is.
He was right about Blumberg writings.
He just had the charges backwards.
Not many people give him credit for that.
So cubic octets of Louis and ad hoc
electrostatic force law like this see over
our term in there,
soon disappeared from Conventional
Chemistry and physics immediately.
In fact,
I mean within a month say okay.
But the idea of shared pairs and lone
pairs that Lewis came up with remained
useful tools for discussing
structure and bonding. Right?
So we still do them.
And that's why you did problems today
that had to do with that? Yes, Nico,
yes.
Yeah. But I won't do it for a week.
Still does. It takes a little while.
Okay.
So Earnshaw said there's no structure
of minimum energy for point charges,
right?
That is no classical one.
But if you come to quantum mechanics
and fiddle around with kinetic energy,
then you can get it. Okay.
But despite Earnshaw,
might Lewis have been right?
Might there still be shared
pair bonds and lone pairs?
What are bonds? Okay. And that's
what we're going to try to find out.
And how do you know or how do you know,
how are we going to know whether their
electron payers and whether that are
shared between Adams and lone pairs
on on Adams? How can we find out?
All right, you got to do an
experiment. So what kind of experiment?
Now these experiments are tough.
Why are the experiments tough?
Cause things are, well
we, we, we could see our,
we could feel whether these
electron pairs are there, right?
But there's a problem as you say,
that it's inconceivably small.
The thing we're looking
for to see or to feel okay,
but does it really inconceivable
how small they are?
I mean when I was in your place,
everybody thought,
yeah there is conceivably
small, we'll forget it. Right?
But there are more recent techniques that
suggest that you can really see things
that small. You're at least you
can think about them clearly. Okay.
Now the first idea of seeing
them came from this book here.
Actually this book was published a look,
this is a third edition of the book.
The first edition was 19 nine,
and the second was 19, 19.
And this is the, uh, third
edition, which is still in print.
You can go on the web and buy this baby,
a cult chemistry,
a series of clairvoyant observations on
the chemical elements by Annie Bessant
and Charles Leadbeater.
So these are the occult chemists who
started practicing their trade in 1895.
A Bishop Charles Webster or led beater.
He was a bishop of the
church he founded that had,
he was the head bishop there were like,
um,
a hundred bishops and 500
members of the religion. Uh,
this is Annie Bessant who is one of
the most interesting people in all of
history.
Uh,
they closed the stock exchange in
India when she, the day she died,
for example,
this is her,
the outfit she designed to
lead the boy scouts in, in, uh,
in India. And she, uh,
she also proposed marriage
to George Bernard Shaw.
There are all sorts of interesting
things about Annie Bessant,
but one of the thing we're interested
in is that she could see Adams
and then they're,
they're a helper who became leader of the,
of the operation later on
was Gina Raja Dasa. Okay,
so this is a page from this book,
from the paper that became the book in
1895 which shows what they could see for
hydrogen, oxygen, and nitrogen. Now
there are a number of levels here.
The very lowest phase is
solid, h, o, n, then liquid,
then gas. So this is what, when
they went into sort of a trance,
they could see right that this is the gas,
but then there's a therial for
ethereal three ethereal too,
and the theorial one phases as well,
that with higher and higher resolution,
you can see these. So these, for example,
these little dots that you see
here are what get blown up here.
And the little things inside
this are what get blown up here.
And the things inside
this get blown up here.
And the things inside this are this.
And that's the same for all atoms.
That's the fundamental
unit. Okay? So here's,
here's hydrogen at the
gas resolution level.
So their wheels in wheels in wheels here.
And here's what oxygen looks like.
It's these little Heela CS,
okay?
And now that's the thing,
you finally get to the thing called
[inaudible] and that they actually ripped
off from this book,
the principals of color,
which was published in America
in 1878 by Edwin d Babbitt.
And here's his picture of this thing.
And Lo and behold,
that's what they saw as the
fundamental constituent of matter.
It's fun to look at in detail. You can
look at it that the web if you want to.
They also has pictures of,
of the Angel of innocence here and uh,
the psycho magnetic curves
around in your head, okay?
Okay. Now, Lo and behold,
the real confirmation of this thing was
that if you counted up the anu in the
different elements, there were
18, I knew in hydrogen, uh,
290 and oxygen and 261 and nitrogen.
And if you divide that by 18,
you get the atomic weights.
Que E d.
Okay?
Okay, so they have pictures in this book
of a bunch of the Adams. This is helium,
which has 72 all new.
This is lithium was 127 on new,
not the bottom part. This is the,
this is a model and this is
the wooden base it sits on.
Here's iron thousand and eight Anu.
Here's neon 360 on new.
Now look at neon.
Yeah.
And that is a four f orbital electron
density calculated by quantum mechanics.
Now the question is why would you believe
me or believe a textbook or believe a
quantum mechanicians and not believe them?
Because they said they
saw it too. Okay, well,
it takes time that we've
talked about this before.
The basis for scientific belief evidence,
you always cross examine an assertion,
logic and taste,
but taste matures with experience and
at the beginning you don't know which
people to believe in which not to believe.
That's a problem in politics too.
Okay?
There's sodium 418 they not
only said they saw Adam's,
they also saw molecules.
For example,
here is sodium carbonate.
What do you see in there?
Right? Two sodiums, right? Okay.
In the back are pieces of a carbon atom.
What else do you see?
Ah,
there are three oxygen heela sees wrapped
around the sodium and the carbon and
they wrote note that this triangular
arrangement of o three has just been
deduced by Bragg from his
ex-ray analysis of calcite.
We'll talk about brag and what
he was doing next time, right?
But they have experimental evidence
that supports what they're reporting
independent experimental evidence.
Okay,
here's their model of benzene
and they say about that.
Each of the three valence as of each
carbon are satisfied by hydrogen and the
fourth veil and see which some of
postulated as going to the interior of the
molecule does actually do so.
In fact,
Annie Bessant was the first woman to get
a degree in chemistry at the University
of London,
but that's another story.
Her teacher was the guy who translated
dust copy towel into English and had a
lot other nefarious things that he did.
Uh,
questions six we'll have to do with that.
Okay,
so here's benzene and its resonance.
These were structures that
were first early proposed.
We'll talk about that later on,
but some people didn't like this idea of
going back and forth between two things
and they thought that you just have the
fourth valence of every carbon going
into the middle, right.
All satisfying one another.
So this was, this was what they said,
that their model confirmed that the law,
the fourth valence of every
carbon goes into the middle.
Okay. Uh, needless to say,
most people nowadays think,
don't think too much of a cult chemistry.
Even if you can still buy the book online.
Okay.
This portal you came through this morning,
it says a 1921,
but here's the same place in 1923
when the building was dedicated,
then you notice those plaques weren't
carved yet. It didn't say erected in 1921,
they were still finished in the building.
At the time,
the American Chemical Society had their
national meeting here to celebrate the
biggest academic building
for chemistry in the world.
Okay. So the slates, we're clean now.
If you go down into the crowd here,
you'll see some interesting people.
For example, there's Jia
and Lewis with his, uh,
with his Philippines cigar in his hand.
He always had his ear.
He smoked 17 cigars a day,
grown.
Okay.
But they were trying to decide how to
decorate all these plaques around the
building and they wanted to put the
names of distinguished American chemists.
Had they done that,
it would be pretty much a disaster
because the people who were thought to be
distinguished American chemists in
those days were not so hot actually in
retrospect,
but they chose a wonderful group and
the idea came from Joseppe Bruni from
Velonia who had came to, who had come
to the meeting to speak and he said,
don't put living chemists
there. Okay. Put dead chemists.
And that's what they did.
In almost all cases they were dead.
And it's a wonderful group as we've
already used Farah Day, remember?
Okay,
here's one of them that's over in that
corner of the building and Van Hoff you
have you heard of Anton [inaudible]?
You'll have heard a lot of him by the
end of this semester. And Gibbs. Yeah,
it gives,
we'll talk about him too.
And men delay if you've
turned who've heard of,
but I suspect that crux
is not so familiar to you.
This is Sir William Crookes,
who was fellow of the Royal Society
and and fts in 1861 he discovered the
element thallium. He also developed a
cathode ray tube, which is holding there,
which you know, became the X-ray tube
and he invented the Crooks radiometer.
I bet every one of you have seen
a crooks radiometer. Do you know
there's a picture of a crux radiometer
to measure the intensity of light by how
fast it spins.
You've seen these things you
buy in novelty stores and
sit there and spin in the
light.
Okay.
From 1913 to 1916 he was
president of the Royal Society.
The same thing that was
founded back by Boyle.
Remember in Robert Hooks and those guys
in 1898 he was president of the British
Association for the advancement of
science and he was also in that year
president of the Society for
psychical research. Right.
And fts is fellow of the
theosophical society,
right? It is. It is a presidential
lecture to the British Association.
For the advancement of science.
One of the things he said was telepathic
research does not yet enlist the
interest of the majority of
my scientific brethren. Okay.
But he's the guy who supplied the
samples for the four Leadbeater and,
and, uh, Bessant to look at. He supplied
them with lithium, chromium, selenium,
titanium, vanadium, Boron,
and beryllium samples so that they could
draw these pictures of what they saw by
clairvoyance. So you can read more
on the web if you want to about him.
He's an interesting character and
there were a lot of semi, well,
really serious scientists.
Oliver Lodge was another one who invented
radio and was head of the physics
department at Bristol,
I think,
who was into communicating with
the dead and stuff like that.
So it wasn't obvious at the beginning
who you should believe and who you
shouldn't believe,
right.
But to get back to the point and
forget clairvoyance for awhile,
which I don't believe
in, uh, the question is,
are molecules and observably small
for what Newton called Vulgar eyes?
Is there no way we can see something
and major at that? That's that small?
So consider water.
Uh,
a cubic centimeter of water is
an 18th of a mold since, uh,
the, uh, molecular weight is 18,
that means it's six 18 says times 10
to the 23rd molecules in a cc of water.
Now,
that's a really,
really big number and it sounds like
they must be just impossibly small,
hopeless to try to see such a thing.
But the difference is between
the cube and the cube root.
Because when we measure distance,
we made your linear not volume.
So to get something about distances,
you take the cube root of the volume.
So if we take the cube root of that,
it's about three times 10 to the seventh.
Now that's still a very big number.
30 million,
right?
But it's not impossibly
small that it's about three.
Onx drums is this dimension the
size of a water molecule. Remember,
we'll talk a lot about a carbon bond,
carbon carbon bond being about
one and a half on streams.
Okay, now think about
10 to the fifth. Okay,
so this lecture room is
about 10 meters wide, okay?
One of my hairs is order of
magnitude 100 microns in diameter.
And that's a ratio of 10 to the fifth,
right?
So 10 to the fifth of my hair's
sideways would go across this room.
So that's a lot,
right?
But it's not impossible to think of
lining up pairs to go across the room or
putting them side by side to take a while.
But it's not impossible to
think about that. The hair
compared to the room. Right.
But a molecule is about a nano meter and
a small Adam is about a 10th of a nano
meter or an onstar. Right. And
that ratio is 10 to the fifth.
So the room to my hair is like my
hair to a molecule or even an atom.
Right? A Big Adam. So it's not
impossibly small, it's just very,
very small.
Okay.
In fact, the nucleus is
10 femto meters, right?
Which is another 10 to the fifth
down. So that means if, if the,
the room where the lecture room,
we're an atom,
the nucleus would be the diameter
of a hair. Right. Very small,
but not impossibly small to conceive of.
Okay.
Now Newton in optics,
the book we looked at before
in 1717 wrote on page three 69,
the thickness of the plate where it
appears very black is three eighths of the
1,000 thousandth part of an inch
is that means he knew the size of it.
Now how big is three eighths of the
1,000 thousandth part of an inch? Well,
1,000 thousand is a million,
right?
Three eighths of a millionth of
an inch is 30 water molecules.
So Somehow Newton was able
to measure something in 1717.
That was the size of 30 water molecules.
Now what tool
could Newton possibly have had in 1717
that allowed him to measure something.
So very small.
What?
I can't hear very well.
Glass Springs. Ah Right,
that's right. Okay. So
here it is. Newton's rings,
which really should be called hooks
rings because he's the guy that had
micrographia that published why?
How they work.
But remember they had different
light theories. So here are two,
two pieces of glass
to glass and I'll change the light.
So we see light through it.
And, uh, now I can't
remember which is which.
But let me guess that if I put this
one over here, having turned it over
that press on it. So let's see.
Okay. Oh, I can see it here.
Can you see? Yeah, you can see,
see those patterns you've seen things like
that with microscopes. Slides, colors.
Okay. So these are two
flats against one another.
They get very close to one another.
But if I turned the top one over,
yeah,
you see that it's a little bit, uh,
let me, so that's what we just saw.
But notice that if I turn it over,
there's a little there,
there turns out here at the edge to be
a little bit of a gap because the top,
when it's just very slightly curved and
now let me see if I can see something
here. Can't see it yet.
Let me just zoom in
and we're going to need to focus on that.
Yeah, I know. Let's
watch. Ah, see that thing,
do that.
I need help. Will you come up and
help me? So you need to zoom in.
Well, I, well I'm trying to
keep that thing in the middle.
It's right. See it says
zoom plus over here. Yes.
Okay. Is there a not it. Okay. There.
Now the, the auto focus is zooming in and
out on this back. We've lost it. Okay.
Uh, let me try something
here. Oh, you see it
there?
Okay. So, so here's what you're seeing
in the middle is what's
called Newton's rings.
They look like that different colors.
Right.
And Newton could measure the thickness
of the air gap that caused different
colors.
The colors repeat right in higher orders.
Okay.
Now,
how could he know the distance so he
could associate every color with a
distance?
How could he know the distance?
Yeah,
because he could measure
the diameter of the rings.
Yeah.
And he said this observation six,
the diameter of the sixth ring, right?
One, two, three, four, five, six.
At the most lucid part of its
orbit was 58 hundredths of an inch.
And the diameter of the sphere on which
the double convex object glass was
ground was about 102 feet.
Hence,
I gathered the thickness of the air or
aerial interval of the glasses in that
ring. So in other words, here's
the air gap is trying to measure,
which is the sixth ring out,
right?
He knows the diameter of that ring.
He knows that they touch in the
middle of the two glasses, right?
And he knows that it's a sphere
and it has a radius of 51 feet.
So he can just use trigonometry
to figure out that the air gap,
if he knows that angle there,
the air gap is a 1.8 microns,
right?
So that's a lot bigger than a Adam.
But if you go into the first ring or even
closer, then you can measure it, right?
So all he needed was a spherical
glass with a very large radius,
and he could measure these distances,
okay,
but here's the simpler of an even
smaller distance about 100 years later.
And here's the guy who did it.
You know who that is?
Benjamin Franklin, of course, we'll
get back to the artists later on.
So he published in the philosophical
transactions of the royal society in 1774.
This society is now 100 years,
110 years old,
114 hundred and 14 years old.
Uh,
this article on the stilling
of waves by means of oil.
Can you see what that means?
What's that related to a common saying,
pouring oil on troubled waters,
if you heard of that one.
So the stilling of waves by means of oil
extracted from sundry letters between
Franklin and Brownrigg.
Okay,
so he wrote to Brownrigg 1773 I had
when a youth red and smiled at plenty's
account of a practice among the semen
of his time to still the waves and the
storm by pouring oil into the c l as well
as the use made of oil by the divers.
Pearl divers would fill their mouth
with oil and when they went down,
if a breeze came up and
ruffled the surface,
which made it hard to see because the
light wouldn't come through clearly,
then they'd let oil out of their mouths.
It would float to the surface,
stop the ripples and they
could see to get their pearls.
This is what plenty said. Right?
But he said he smiled at that.
But a quaint thing to think,
right. It's like the like the uh,
a cult chemists.
I think that it is been of late,
too much the mode to slight
the learning of the ancients,
the learner to are apt to slight too
much the knowledge of the vulgar.
Right in 1757 being at sea and a fleet
of 96 sale bound against Louis Burgoff,
Cape Breton Island,
I observed the wakes of two of the ships
to be remarkably smooth while all the
others were ruffled by the wind,
which blew fresh.
Being puzzled with the
differing appearance.
I at last pointed that out to our
captain and asked him the meaning of it.
The cooks said he have,
I suppose just been emptying their
greasy water through the scuppers,
which has greased the sides
of those ships a little.
So there's experimental evidence
for what plenty said. Okay.
Recollecting what I had
formerly read in plenty.
I resolve to make some experiments of
the effect of oil on water when I should
have the opportunity. And when he had the
opportunity was when he was in London.
So here's London and his experiment in
1762 was in that place on clap on common
in south London
at length being a clap them where
there is on the common a large pond,
which I observed one day to
be very rough with the wind.
I fetched out a crew at of oil and
dropped a little of it on the water.
I saw it spread itself with
surprising swiftness upon the surface,
but the effect of smooth,
smoothly in the waves was not produced.
So the experiment was a failure.
Okay.
Four I had applied at first on the lured
side of the pond where the waves were
greatest and the wind drove
by oil back along the shore.
So it didn't spread on the
surface. Right. So what did he do?
Go to the other side. Right. I then went
to the windward side where they began,
the waves began to form, and there are
the oil though not more than a teaspoon,
fall produced an instant
calm over a space,
several yards square,
which spread amazingly and extended
itself gradually to let reach the least
side,
making all that quarter of the pond,
perhaps half an acre as
smooth as a looking glass.
So a teaspoon is five cubic centimeters
and he stilled half an acre,
which is 2000 square meters,
which means that the
thickness of this layer,
right to spread that many
cubic centimeters over 2000
square meters would be 25
OnX drums,
which is the length of a molecule
of the fat that's in the oil.
So Franklin had in fact measured
the length of an oil molecule
in this way.
Right now he didn't think he had measured
it and didn't claim to have measured
it. He said, when I put on the
water, it spreads instantly,
many feet around becoming so thin
as to produce the prismatic colors.
The Newton rings colors,
right,
for a considerable space and beyond them,
so much thinner.
It became so thin that you didn't
even get Newton's colors right.
So much thinner as to be invisible except
in its effective smoothing the waves
at much greater distance. So with the
technique was stilling the water right.
Allows you to measure
how big the area was.
Isn't that cool?
Okay.
It seems as if a mutual repulsion between
the particles took place as soon as it
touched the water that is,
they pressed one another apart and moved.
So what he wouldn't have known
was that they stay, they,
they've pushed one another apartment,
they stayed in contact with one another,
right. To become a motto, molecular
thick layer over the water.
So he didn't claim to have majored it,
but indeed he did measure
the size of it oil.
So these things are the
size of an oil molecule. So,
so molecules are very, very, very small,
but they're not inconceivably small and
there are ways you can measure them.
Okay,
so we have this question,
are there electron pairs?
So let's try first feeling with
scanning probe microscopy or Spm,
can we feel individual molecules?
Can we feel individual atoms?
Can we see what bonds are by feeling them?
Right?
So a scanning tunneling,
tunneling microscopy was invented
in 1981 by these guys in Zurich,
Garrett Benish and Heinrich's Rohrer.
And here's the first publication.
But they,
they worked at IBM and here's the
first publication on the cover of their
journal about a meeting about this new
technique, scanning tunneling microscopy,
and they got the Nobel prize within
five years. Or maybe it was even less.
Very short order in 1986.
Okay.
Now how does, how does that
scanning tunneling microscopy,
which is one type of SPM scanning,
probe,
scanning tunneling is one way,
and I'll mention that shortly,
but first I'm going to talk
about atomic force microscopy.
And for this you need a little chip
and I'll show you the chip is in here.
Yeah.
In this little a bug box. Uh,
you can't see it here. Well,
there's the chip in the middle, right?
And I'll pass it around so you can look,
look at it.
And if you,
if you tilt it so that the light from
the ceiling glints off the off the gold
and you'll see it really shiny, you
may be able to see it. The thin end,
these little V's,
right?
You can see here at the bottom, Little
V's, the chip is 1.4 millimeters wide.
It's a gold coated silicon chip.
And if you look at those with
even higher magnification,
you see this and there's the size
of a hair you can actually see,
did you see them? They're not easy to
see and maybe you will. Maybe it won't,
but they're there. Okay? So
there's the size of a hair.
And in any given experiment,
you have a choice of five different
canta leavers as they're called,
that you can use. Okay? Here's a,
a higher resolution electron micrograph
that shows the tip of one of these V's
and you'll see a little,
um,
a little bulge here at the bottom.
And if you zoom in on that,
yeah,
you see this,
it's a little pyramid.
Yeah.
And so at the bottom of that pyramid,
the radius of curvature of this
tip is only about 20 nanometers.
So about the size of 20 molecules,
right? It's raw, it's round on the tip.
It's not truly pointed to come to
nothing, right? It's a little bit rounded.
You can buy that are that are uh,
a third that size.
They're curved radius of curvature.
Okay.
And then you have this piece of glass,
I said,
do not touch when you came in because
that piece of glass costs $2,000.
Let's see,
you got it back up here.
Okay. So there's this piece of
glass and if I hold it up here,
there's that little, a little chip
on the bottom of the piece of glass.
I know what I'm looking for. I don't know
if you can see it or not. But anyhow,
it's held into this piece of stuff here.
And those little tips
are pointing up here.
But the fact the thing is used
upside down so they point down.
So here's that thing mounted in an
instrument and you see there's a red light
glowing in the glass.
And the reason is it's
being irradiated by there.
So there's a blown up picture of one of
these tips pointing down and laser light
comes and bounces off the shiny gold
on this tip and gets reflected up to a
detector. Now, what would happen
if you pushed up on the tip?
It would deviate the reflection,
right? It would go like this.
Yeah.
And you have a very precise, uh, uh,
position detector for the laser light
up where you see it, the light glowing.
So you can tell the deviation of that
tip moving up and down by a size that's
less than an atom.
That neat.
So now what you do in this is move this
back and forth over the sample and watch
the little needle go up and down by the
reflection of the light. So if you had,
if the surface was like this
is go click, click, click,
click, click, click up, up, up,
up, up, up, right as you scan across,
right?
And it sensitive, as I say, to less
than one molecule change in height,
although it doesn't feel an individual
molecule because the tip or a member is
20 nanometers wide,
right?
So the tip is the width of the
tip is like a hundred or so, uh,
Adams, right? So it's, it's touching
a bunch of atoms at any one time.
But if you come to a
ledge on like a crystal,
it would be going to the certain height,
touching a bunch,
and then it would move up and touch a
bunch more and you'd be able to tell that
it went up and down if, if that
distance was only one molecule easy.
Here's in fact a picture taken by an
undergraduate. In fact, it's a movie.
So it's AFM traces. So what you do is like
a TV, you know where you go, zoom, zoom,
zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom,
zoom. And then you go back
to the top, zoom, zoom, zoom,
zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom. Say how high
it is at every point along the scan,
and then color coded to show how high.
So the width of this is
about 600 molecules, right?
But the lines you see,
which are legends that
go up and those ledge,
each of those legends is one unit cell,
1.7 nanometers,
one set of molecules. So
these are, and that the,
the thing of the, the top surface where
it's flat is absolutely flat, right?
Except for those little holes there and
those holes were made by taking this tip
and pressing down and scratching a little
bit to knock some of the molecules away
so that the larger pit
is five nanometers deep,
which means it's four layers of molecules
been knocked off in there and now this
is underwater or underwater and propanol.
So the crystal is dissolving slowly.
So those pits open up
as molecules come away.
So Watch,
right?
Those are at one minute intervals.
So we're actually feeling individual
molecular heights with this thing.
There was an interesting point here
that I'm not going to dwell on,
but the smallest one did
not lose any molecules.
If I back up watch the smallest one,
it always stays the same
size as the others dissolve.
That's an interesting puzzle. Isn't
it? But at any rate, you can do it.
So the,
and you can measure the rate at which
different ledges dissolve some dissolved
much faster than others.
Here's a,
uh, a scanning tunneling microscopy.
This is done a different way.
It's not that you don't reflect the laser
light. What you do is detect the, uh,
electrical conductivity through a layer.
And if you have an Adam there that
is a good conductor of electricity,
you get more lot more current through and
last and so on. So as you scan a real,
now this could be a really,
really sharp tip where the tip is
just one atom or a couple Adams.
So now as you go across, you can feel
things that are much smaller laterally.
Okay? So this picture here, that thing
right there, which is as you see,
a repeated pattern, that's one of
those molecules with see 12 in it,
in a bromine on the end. And here's
a model that shows what the, uh,
what the, what the molecule looks
like. The yellow is, is a bromine.
The brown or the two oxygens and the
green are carbon and the gray are
hydrogens.
They don't come colored that way.
They come looking like
this as to conductivity.
But you can see individual atoms,
right?
Or one of the more dramatic early
examples in 1993 was that the IBM labs at
Almaden and in California where they
worked on iron atoms on the surface of
copper,
and they use this tip and changing the
voltage to pick up Adams and move them
where they wanted. Then change
the voltage and drop them there.
Then go back and get another one
and do it. So they made this thing,
they called a quantum corral of whatever,
58 or something.
A iron atoms.
Yeah.
Pardon me. This along the
lines of when they, oh yeah,
they also spelled out IBM.
Right.
They knew which side their
bread was buttered on too,
just like the Royal Society did.
Okay. So that's, that's neat.
So clearly you can see individually
or feel individual atoms,
right?
But you don't see the bonds.
The bonds are smaller. It just
looks like a bunch of balls. Right?
You don't see the electron
pairs between them.
Here's Snob.
SNOB stands for scanning near
field optical microscope.
So this is in a sense seeing, but
actually it's scanning. It's like,
it's like feeling.
So what you have here is a glass fiber
that's drawn down to a very sharp point
and coated with aluminum.
And the hole at the bottom
is just a hundred nanometers.
That's like a hundred molecules,
right? Not, not really,
really tiny like the scanning
tunneling microscope.
So what you do is you have something on
the surface of a slide there that you
want to probe with this and
you send light down the thing.
And if there is a molecule where the
light's coming out through this tiny hole,
if there's a molecule there that will
take the blue light and emit red light,
then you know when it's under the tip,
suppose there was just one
molecule on the whole slide,
you scan it around until
suddenly red light comes out.
Then you know that tip is pointed
toward that particular molecule. Okay?
So red light comes out and you have a
detector that detects it and you scan the
sample back and forth
like a TV, right? And uh,
and you find out where such molecules are.
And here's a picture taken in that way.
So this is a scale of microns,
right? Two, two by two microns. In fact,
it's a distorted scale as I see here.
Okay?
And that's that Arrow double headed
Arrow is the wavelength of red light.
So you're seeing things significantly
smaller than the wavelength of the light
having done this way,
you're not really looking with your eye.
You're doing this scanning
trick, right? Okay.
So scanning probe microscopy is like
atomic force microscopy, scanning,
tunneling,
my cross scopy scanning nearfield
optical microscopy are really powerful.
And you can see individual Adams,
right?
The sharp points can resolve
individual molecules and even Adams,
but not bonds. So it's not doing
what we need to do for our purposes.
Now that's a, I'm going to
spend the last few minutes, uh,
going over the problem that we
were looking at with a member.
You were supposed to draw
all the resonance structures
for Hco n Isomers I think
you remember that. Okay,
so let's just look at it.
So what we're going to do is compare
what we see with Lewis theory with things
that have been calculated by
reasonably good quantum mechanics.
Not the very, very highest
level, but pretty good level.
Uh,
okay.
So we want to try to make all the possible
arrangements here so we can put the
three atoms OCN with any
one of them in the middle,
and then we can put hydrogen
on either end, right?
So then we'll do it with nitrogen in the
middle, then with oxygen in the middle.
So we'll have done all possibilities
there. So here are two possibilities.
Now are these good structures
is what we have to decide. Okay.
Now it would be possible to shift
electrons here and draw different Lewis
structure.
Which of those two do you think is better?
Why?
Okay, there's separation of
charge on the bottom. Okay.
So there's bad charge separation.
Uh,
most the most electronegative atom
oxygen in fact, has a positive charge,
not a negative charge. Right? So that's
not only is their charge separation,
it's in the wrong direction,
but they're all octets that
we've drawn in both structures.
All Adams have octets now let's
try the same trick over here.
We can do it that way. How about
that? Which of those is better?
Okay.
In both structures we could go through
and count and see that they're all octets.
Right.
That would you like me to do that or
is that something that's become second
nature to you by now? That he may want
me to count them. Okay, you got that,
but now which of those two
structures do you think is better?
Yeah.
And and, okay, so you
say the top ones better,
you say because it doesn't have charge
separation now as compared to the case on
the left. Which do you think if you
have to have charged separation,
which one is better?
The one on the right,
because at least at least you have, you
have the, you have with the right Adam,
the oxygen being negative, you could
have drawn the one on the top two.
Right. And that goes the other way. If I,
if I do notice that I've
introduced something here
that I haven't really talked
about enough.
The idea of curved arrows,
curved arrows show a shift of electrons,
right?
An electron pair.
What would you draw if you wanted
to show just one electron shifting?
If you had to think up the a notation.
Yeah,
dotted curve would be one possibility.
Another possibility Sovi Ah,
hell,
I like a fish hook instead
of a double arrow. Right?
And that's in fact what's used.
If you want to shift just one electron,
you show a uh, a single Barb. And
if you do a pair of electrons,
you show a double barbed curved arrow.
So curved arrows don't show Adam's moving,
they don't show this.
Adam goes to there,
they show an electron pair moving or
sometimes a single electron moving.
And you can use a double or a
single Barb to show which one. Okay,
so get that straight because that's
an off often a problem. Okay.
So the one on top is much worse
than the one on the bottom. Okay.
So there are possibilities
with sea in the middle. Now,
how about if you put in in the middle,
here are two structures with octets now,
uh, well, pardon me? They
don't all have our tests.
That one on the right has assessed that
right cause the carbons making two bonds.
So it gets three electrons out of
those two buttons at the department.
It gets two electrons out of those
two bonds. One from each bond.
That's its share in the
bookkeeping plus an unshared payer.
Right? That's only, well, uh, I mean,
what's associated with it
has only three pertinent,
I'm saying the wrong thing here.
It has four electrons that it calls
its own from bookkeeping point of view,
one from each bond and two in the
unshared payer. So it's not charged.
It came in with four electrons.
It's still got four electrons,
but it participates with only three
pairs of electrons. So it's assessed tet.
So that's not so good on the right.
The one on the left is not so good
because it's charged, separated.
At least it's on oxygen,
right? The negative charge.
We could draw this other one which puts
the negative charge on carbon. That's,
we would say not so good,
right? So that's a bad charge.
Or we could do it that way.
That looks like the best charge.
Probably better to put positive
on carbon than on nitrogen.
Okay.
But that carbon has assessed tet.
The others are octet ones.
Okay.
And we can do this other one over here.
Now we've got an octet on the carbon,
but we've got negative
charge on the carbon.
That's not such a great charge separation
thing. Or we could do it this way,
but again,
we got bad charge.
Okay.
So now if we put oh, in the middle, uh,
we can do these structures,
both of which you notice
have what's bad about them.
Yeah.
Says staff there says
out on the right to uh,
there's a plus charge on
oxygen that's not so great.
You can draw curved arrows and
shift the electron pairs around.
You now got an octet on carbon,
but you've got to assess Ted
on nitrogen and bad charge,
negative on carbon,
not so great.
And over here you can do
that says stat again, charge.
Or you can make the three
heavy atoms into a ring.
And then you could put the hydrogen on
any one of the coming out of any one of
them. Uh, now the one on the left, uh,
with my computer,
I can't calculate it.
I can't find an energy minimum that has
that structure. So that one is very bad,
which doesn't surprise anyone.
It's got horrid angles for the bonds,
although we haven't really said that
we prefer one angle over another,
but it also has bad charge separation.
Okay.
Uh, that one's a bad charge. So, uh,
we could draw this other one here,
but still got positive on
oxygen. Assess tete. Uh,
what do we have here?
Says Ted on carbon. Uh,
okay.
So here are the bunch of isomers
we've just gone through right now.
A couple of years ago when I first talked
about this in the class and when they,
when these things had been accurately
calculate as accurately as people are
likely to do to calculate their
true energy and structure,
I,
uh,
I tested my colleagues in the department
to ask them if they could rank these
things as to what's the lowest than
what's the highest energy. And so on,
and no one succeeded.
In fact,
only a few people get the no,
which the lowest one is on the basis
of their familiarity with Lewis theory.
So the point is,
don't be depressed when you went,
when you are trying to do this,
it takes a lot of lore and even with
all the lore that's that's been gathered
over many years,
people can't use Lewis theory for this
purpose because it's just not that good,
okay?
But in fact,
the way I've drawn them there is their
energy according to these pretty good
calculations,
right?
The very lowest energy is the c in the
middle and I h on the nitrogen and then
see in the middle and h on the oxygen.
Now you can go back and look at what we
said was good and bad about these things
and convince yourself that now,
now you understand why those are on
the bottom and these are on the top.
But if it had come out differently,
you would have convinced
yourself differently. Okay,
so that's enough for today.
Actually there's a, there's a,
there's a reference for
this if you want to see it.
It was that the energies were published
in the Journal of Chemical Physics in
2004.